السؤال الذي يواجه تركيا الان هو ما الذي
سيفعله زعيم التركي بعد ذلك صحيفه بلوتو
الامريكيه القت الضوء على اراء انصار
اردوغان كما منتقدي فيما يخص النهج الذي
سيتبعه في السياسه الداخليه والخارجيه
منتقدوا اردوغان يقولون ان فوزه سيعكسوا
سيطرته على موارد الدوله بشكل اكثر
وسيواصل سيطرته ايضا على معظم وسائل
الاعلام بالاضافه الى سجن شخصيات بارزه في
المعارضه والمجتمع المدني كما ان خمس
سنوات اخرى من حكم اردوغان في السلطه قد
توجه ضربه مدمره للديمقراطيه التركيه وهذا
الخوف الذي اعربت عنه العديد من جماعات
المعارضه بينما يرد انصار اردوغان بان
التصويت يعكس تقدير الاتراك لسنوات
اردوغان العشرين في منصبه اولا كرئيس
للوزراء ومن ثم كرئيس للبلاد يقول
انصار اردوغان ان البلاد اقوى بكثير مما
كانت عليه قبل 20 عاما بسبب النمو
الاقتصادي وتحسين البناء التحتيه بالاضافه
الى دور تركي اكثر نشاطا في الشؤون
العالميه كما ان اردوغان لا يخشى اتخاذ خط
مستقل عن الغرب وفقا لمؤيديه على الرغم من
كون تركيا عضو في حلف الناتو
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات